[Music]
[Applause]
you like me and i like you you know why
i'm the rhyming jew
as john stamos continues to mourn his
dear friend and full house co-star bob
saget he's reflecting on the late
comedian's life and death on instagram
it's an extended family the truth is
we've always loved each other and that's
what i think made the show a success it
was in between the lines that stuff that
happens when it's real between people
on tuesday the 58-year-old actor posted
a moving montage of sweet moments from
bob's life and career on social media
writing alongside it quote when i saw
his last instagram post my first thought
was he looked too alive to die a few
hours later but when i really thought
about it bob did it right we should all
want to die alive john went on writing
we don't want to be filled with regret
and remorse forgotten and discarded we
want to be overwhelmed with the
privilege of doing what we do best bob
felt young energized grateful and
appreciated he died bright and fierce
to be able to just entertain and
make people laugh and do something just
for the sheer joy i'm really happy and
the sweet tribute resonated with bob's
wife kelly rizzo who shared the video to
her insta story writing these are the
sentiments that are getting me through
love you and love how much you loved bob
he is always with us
[Music]
bob was found unresponsive in a hotel
room in orlando florida and pronounced
dead on january 9th just hours after he
finished a stand-up show outside of
jacksonville he was 65 years old
on friday a private memorial service was
held in los angeles for the late tv star
which was attended by a number of his
full house co-stars including john dave
coulier lachlan candace cameron beret
and the olsen twins among others the
thing that touches me the most they're
friends of mine
they are
really friends of mine it's a gift a
source told et that the service was
quote very special and that all of bob's
favorite people were together in one
room i mean that's a love thing that's
kind of what it is of course bob
continues to be remembered by fans and
friends alike including fellow comedians
gilbert gottfried margaret cho and
tiffany haddish who all opened up to et
about bob's lasting legacy
the people who knew him will remember
him as you know a great guy
really funny really quick and always
outrageous
and just easy i mean i think that he
will be really seen as somebody who
really
loved comedy as much as he was loved
what a great thing what a great person
he was just so naturally funny naturally
ridiculous and i'll miss him a lot
he's always so motivated so kind
he would send me like tell me proud of
me
send me a message we would cry together
like that's my guy
as for tiffany she got teary-eyed
talking to e.t about the late comedian
explaining that bob was more like family
to her you know i met him when i was 16
when i started the life factory comedy
camp so
um
he was always encouraging and kind and
you know like you know you would watch
tv shows and be like oh where's my dad i
wish i had a dad like that he was like
an instantly like a father figure to me
and then i don't know where like around
the time i turned like 21 22 he shifted
from like a father figure type to a big
brother but that was a beacon for me
that was somebody that was one of those
few people that always encouraged me to
be myself
[Music]